since getting back from Christmas break
Hannity's teasing me I've tortured
myself by reading and watching some of
the usual suspects in the media you know
fake news populated by fake thinkers now
there are basically two movements in the
coverage first the manufactured outrage
about what is a partial and obviously
temporary government shutdown Yosemite
the nation's third busiest National Park
they're also having huge problems with
garbage and toilets filled to capacity
park visitors in some places are taking
care of business shall we say along
pathways or in the woods I run it that
the people who are making the decisions
are still getting paid but we have to
not get paid and still do our job live
about a half hour from work and it's
gonna come to a point where you say - I
put gas in my car or do I feed my family
well they haven't missed a paycheck yet
we hope they don't
but by the way second in this coverage
is the downplayed concern about the
actual effect that illegal immigration
has in America because in the meetings
way of thinking it's not a crisis at all
Mike Pence knows he was lying through
his teeth last week when he talked about
the crisis at the southern border goes
to the point of how the president had
one election that there was a crisis at
their border he had to create that sense
of crisis to win and he has to keep the
sense of crisis to keep his popularity
from going even further down okay I am
now completely confused it's a crisis
that certain non-essential government
workers won't be paid starting on Friday
but they'll ultimately get all their
money when the government reopens but
it's not a crisis when just in the past
fiscal year a total of almost 400,000
individuals were caught crossing our
southwest border not to give you a sense
of just how bad it is in October and
November this past year that's the first
two months of the new fiscal year almost
a hundred and two thousand people have
been caught that's quite a clip the
number of people crossing illegally with
children has also skyrocketed and the
Rio Grande Valley sector alone the No
were spiked 27% since last year jumping
from like 49,000 896 fiscal year 2017 to
63,000 278 in the last fiscal year not a
crisis this is and has been a crisis
felt by average Americans far beyond the
comfy confines of TV studios and far
Baja beyond the heady halls of Congress
yet the media and deceitful politicians
only acknowledge the crisis when the
tragedy of an immigrant child makes the
headlines today's visit reaffirm the
fact that the federal government under
the trump administration still has a
long way to go in making sure that
migrants are treated humanely you bet
every life is precious and you bet that
every death is tragic
that's at the border desk beyond the
border but the fault here lies with
irresponsible parents who expose their
children of this perilous journey and
the feckless politicians who refuse to
do their job and support a common-sense
enforcement agenda that the president
has and asylum reform that is beyond
desperately needed now over the past
year I have repeatedly urged the
President to address this critical issue
and not just the wall in a major
primetime address the president needs to
address this from the Oval and this
should become a flashpoint now not after
the middle isn't number this is a crisis
that must be addressed immediately I've
begged him to do this for a year on air
it's the government and immigration
those two issues are the top of the list
for the people the government meaning
working against the people and
immigration that's it
got address the country on that in this
is do not tweets address the country lay
it out well today I'm really glad to see
that he announced he's doing just that
tomorrow night and it's gonna be
followed by a trip to the actual border
McAllen Texas good now I would hope that
when he does this the president
personalizes the border crisis those
statistics I just gave you they're
important but we
need to emphasize how illegal
immigration has directly and at times
tragically affected the lives of all
Americans and including the people
trying to come into the country it's
been dangerous for them the speech
should be wide-ranging hitting all the
big immigration issues from chain
migration to the Visa Lottery the need
for mandatory e-verify in the workplace
and also yeah even the scam of so-called
birthright citizenship you know that's
where children of non-us citizens are
granted automatic citizenship just for
being born here every year thousands of
Chinese Russians and others travel to
the United States to have babies just
for the US passport it's called birth
tourism it was a complete outrage it's
big business and no it's not a
constitutional right so don't try me on
that as for all those who claim by the
way that illegal immigration is not a
crisis I think the American families of
these victims would disagree the day
after christmas california officer Renea
singh was shot in cold blood during a
routine traffic stop he left behind a
wife in a five month old baby his
murderer illegal alien gustavo perez
Arriaga thousands of citizens and
hundreds of officers attended the
funeral service i wish all of you could
watch it and this happened over the
weekend this is the Fiji ambassador the
officer originally hailed from Fiji
speaking at the service and I was
watching him today I hadn't seen it
until today he has a better grasp of
this tragedy than many American
commentators no words can take away
their pains no object can fill the void
in their hearts no embrace can be more
comforting those King can replace their
shattered dreams no death can be more
untimely this is what pronouncing spasm
must mean to those closest to him and
his parents are still alive as well by
the way and then on December 29th 22
year old Pierce Corcoran was killed in a
collision in Knoxville Tennessee
the man who swerved into him took his
life
was another illegal alien Franco come
Ronny Francisco Eduardo my friends the
families of both of these upstanding
Americans are tonight in crisis the
president cannot relent he must continue
to speak for these families and frankly
for the millions of you who believe that
every country not just dark every
country around the world has the
sovereign right to determine who can and
cannot reside here it's not a moral to
do so and if our elected representatives
refuse to do their solemn duty to defend
our country then we in a sense we kind
of already have a government that's shut
down shut down to the will of the people
and by the way that people routinely
rank illegal immigration as one of the
most urgent problems facing this nation
and as for the Republicans on Capitol
Hill think about it for a moment take a
lesson from the Democrats they never
break ranks think about what you
Republicans accomplish by supporting the
president during the confirmation fight
of Brett Kavanaugh when things got tough
when the media were piling on
Republicans stood firm do it again here
the Democrats are desperate to divide
and conquer the GOP don't let them and
that's the angle